I think this stuff this is history here
you are your history this is garbage
I can say I bled for garbage this is
nothing this is just nothing but look at
this heavyweight champion who after
after his fight he was like bismillah
Anthony Anthony Johnson first of all I
want to thank God I want to say
bismillah look at this huge these days
they thrown money here may where they're
always taking the videos with his pack
of money pack of money like maths padam
he's in your camp there your Romero
everyone is over there called becoming
chromatin yeah Maxime Dadaji he was from
Dagestan too and I hear from the
brothers you know wait Dustin Poirier he
said what he said I was treating better
here than it was beating back home
treated better by the Muslim the watches
that he's wearing you see the cars that
he's riding other people because we're
assalamualaikum greetings a peace
welcome to the Deen show and I got a
really we got a lot to talk about I have
a special guest in the studio my brother
your brother Ali Kato cough I said ah
alaikum it's very nice to see we finally
got you in the studio
no hamdulillah how you how you adapt
into the cold no but I thought I thought
people from the from the caucus
mountains over there they're used to the
cold they do 13 years you like the
Florida weather huh yeah all right so
for people don't know you were you grew
up wrestling your whole life you're
trained and you are also doing MMA mixed
martial arts specifically you were doing
cage fighting no rules for I not like
the no rules fighting like you did that
before we are there was no rules before
back in the days this was called punk
rotten and this was a bare-knuckle you
know you can stomp everything you can
hit on a groin or poke in the eye and
there's only rules that's it
uh-huh but the rest you can do jump on
her face where was then Russia yes you
were doing that yeah yeah but then you
got into fighting professionally
yeah professionally whenever may just
start picking up you know this was a
price Fedor Emelianenko was fighting and
stuff like that and then I get into it
back home I started and professional I
start doing it when I get here in
America like about 13 years ago so I'm
like that
yeah I'm still training under the Jeremy
Horn in Utah and this will cure me harm
yeah he was in the UFC Jeremy who had
130 over 130 fights he beat the guys
like a Chael Sonnen he fought like guys
like the ready could - Anderson Silva
yeah big names yeah he was known for his
being very technical on the ground for
it
where'd he learn jujitsu from he's
jujitsu I'm not sure but I know there
was have a team back you remember back
in the days in UFC they have a teams
yeah like a lines something whatever
different different schools you know I
mean his school was the word met Hughes
and Pat Miletich robbie lawler all these
guys was there was their team so yeah he
was very very technical he had a very
good ground game yeah so you were
training with him so you were you were
you were doing you were doing a
professional fighting before now all
these new guys are coming up this way
before them because I'm kind of little
bit older than them but yeah I did this
before them I was actually the first guy
from our country who made it to us and
start compete professional and I mean
you were the first from that rush of the
company because I don't remember
then after was some guys start coming up
to the club like yeah this was a I don't
remember that lon
there's different guys that you know
they just start coming coming coming
coming
so they took out were you guys inspired
also a lot of the guys went because many
people they watch the earlier of season
see hoist Gracie and they see the is
that also you know older boys was
looking at and they want to be there you
know when I was back home I look at them
on TV and I said man this guys are
amazing they probably are beasts then
when I get to the gym and have a chance
to train with them I said man we can do
it too yeah I can't do it too so you
came here before because when you when
you think about Russia now many people
the person who put that area probably
more in the map many people don't know
about even though he was one of the
legends there was the Russian don't know
link oh yeah yeah he was competing back
in the days here but he was in the pride
in remember pride the back in days was
number one uh-huh it was way ahead of
the UFC yes and then you know pride this
crash and UFC pick it up you know if
season different level huh so then you
were your older generation then are you
from because many people now if you
mentioned this area they know it because
of Habib
yeah - yeah so where was he at was he
fighting when you were fighting he was
doing a Samba and stuff like that you
know he's younger than me every age
difference but he was
been doing some boy he was competing it
was very successful is most of the guys
over there back in the days they did as
I know he was being in Ukraine I think
his father was a head coach over there
zomb or something like that I know he
was competing and he was very successful
in [ __ ] and stuff like that
yeah that's time we were talking last
time we spoke or before that we were
talking about that you you were actually
you've been in his corner you know him
very well you guys come from that same
era it was we were have it the same
manager you know I mean for all of us
mostly yeah and the way he's manager you
know put me in his corner when he was a
fighting in Orlando against the in Habib
this corner yeah Sonya Sonya see so he
fought the Sun yes and this is the the
time first time we met have people over
there I was in scoring everything you
know from there yeah so many people now
they they don't know that you actually
what was the reason you actually left
because how long did you actually fight
for how long were you a professional
fighter for been fighting for minimum
like 10 to 12 years man 10 to 12 years
it's my pro and I don't even count the
amateur carrier because the amateur have
been very long time that was competing
wrestling kickboxing I did hand-to-hand
fighting this what we called you know I
mean in competing all different type of
stuff then they came here a father
amateur a lot of amateur fights in MMA
for over a decade
yeah then they start fighting
professionally you know I get to the
Dean you know as I started learning
about the religion you know I find out
what's Haram I get deeper into it you
know I find out it straight Hadees when
you cannot do this so people don't know
when they hear Dean now so now he pretty
much means that you started to reflect
and you started to think about what's my
purpose in life exactly because those
are the questions that many people I
mean it's is very simple the concept
because that Mike that you're using a
speak has a purpose you using the
jackets more here because that jacket
has a purpose if you want everything
have a purpose in this life but so you
start to think what's my purpose
you know and start to look into the
Quran start to study the religion you
know and does explain you everything why
you created why you here with your
purpose you know I mean the God give us
a freedom of the choice but in the end
everyone have to pay there's like you're
going to the supermarket you can buy it
you can get the car and if you put
anything inside but in the end is the
cashier you have to pay for it yeah
that's a good point so the same with the
life you know we're living the life and
you cannot say oh I didn't know because
God send you prophet after prophet after
prophet and he bring you the books to
live by yeah and you cannot say oh I
didn't know how to do and he don't send
the angel or some specialists and the
humans just like us you know to teach us
to guide us and to explain us why we're
here what we're doing here yeah and you
know I'm do luck I'll open my eyes you
know and I'm very grateful but you don't
you don't come from a background you
weren't someone who was born into a
Muslim family born in a Christian family
actually Orthodox Christians yeah my my
mom's side too is was Muslims but
there's what we call the traditional
Muslims you know back in Civic Union you
know how was they take their religion
away from the people so people was
living without religion they just say
I'm Muslim or I'm Christian when they
didn't even know nothing about the
religion because back in the days over
there people was hiding the books and
stuff like this you know this was pretty
bad they were hiding the books here they
was hiding the Quran see I showed the
videos on YouTube when the people after
the Soviet Union is break now they was
hiding the books on the walls you know
the build-up I saw that yes I saw that
yeah yeah trying to keep the the
knowledge away from the people I heard
right now it who girl Muslims what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to change the actual text of the Quran
and the Bible yeah they got it up to
that point those companies and do to the
people you know yeah but but this this
is another proof in and of itself that
you cannot suppress what's just innately
intrinsically built in you to believe in
the almighty in the Creator
that after all this time how long was
communism over there exactly and it's
supposed to be by today's supposed to be
no religion in earth at all yeah but
guess what every person born with the
God in his heart and he was always good
and trying to reach to his creator yeah
this is just how we are
and the people right now actually in
Russia you're gonna be impressed you see
the people who go through the cabin ISM
the young people young generation the
sisters is covered you see a lot of
sisters wearing the niqab you see a lot
of brothers grown to the beard you know
and subhanAllah dislike a lot of people
is right now is going to study they
learn the religion a lot of Russians
themselves convert to the Islam you know
like a lot of the promises the light of
Islam is never gonna be shut down you
know so this is amazing and this was
showing me the truth about this religion
you know doesn't matter how people try
to put down spread the bad words about
the Muslims we the most biggest Ummah in
the world we're growing every day and I
hear I think in London right the
Mohammed is one of the famous name over
there yeah yeah yeah so it just shows
because Allah the Creator has an earth
saying that he's gonna be exalted and
you see you know to this day you know
every time just you even here in this
country you had it in the Supreme Court
him labeled as one of the the the most
famous of law givers they honored the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Muhammad
Ali right he's amazing where they have
the the walk of the stars yeah when
you're into this life particularly we're
talking about let's say you're in the
spotlight now you're chasing you see
Conor McGregor yeah someone like that
and you see the the watches that he's
wearing you see the cars that he's
riding other people because we're
creatures of imitation we see that were
attracted to it so the man wants to hook
up with more women he wants to fulfill
his desires has lost his passions so he
wants the money so he wants to get the
belt and wants to win that belt
so then what he can have all the perks
as we say that come with it but they're
not thinking of
were you so what had that divide happen
your lie because you're like okay I'm
doing this I need to hit the big payoff
there's not much money at still right is
there is how's the money now with
compared to NFL NBA basketball
you're busting your butt to get all
these injuries very little so you're
looking to get that big payoff so then
you get all the perks now here you come
a long thinking about what's my purpose
in life but other people are not
thinking about that yeah you you know
you're going simply you're gonna go to
the graveyard then you're gonna look at
this whole can you get your cars your
money your watch your fame over there
your family is gonna be over there with
you they cry one day your friends
everybody two weeks three weeks the most
is a one-year you're gonna be forgotten
there's a matter how good you was have
famous you was you gone
where's the people who've been here a
hundred years ago we don't know them we
don't hear about them you gone so what
next you know I mean this is we have to
think about what next you know we you
can don't believe in God you can argue
about the religion you cannot argue
about the death you're gonna die you
know I mean in what after Wow what after
so you have to think about this you know
this is the best when I was going to the
graveyard and I see how they put the man
over there and I imagine myself in this
hole you know and what you know some
people say what are you gonna do if
you're gonna find out that God is not
there after you die I say you're gonna
feel worse if you're gonna find out he's
there no I mean so Norman so this was
amazing me you know when I'm start
thinking like you know all this is just
dunya you know this life is doesn't
matter this materialistic stuff is
doesn't matter man it doesn't mean
nothing because you know Weiser that's
just the fitnah you know you want this
you want that you want a woman you want
to be famous you want but the in the end
of the day man
like okay is a fighter you're winning
you're winning one lost that said you
forgot like Hobby right now he's
fighting if you're gonna lose to the
tenant Ferguson people gonna forget but
this is just the nature of the people
they don't remember 99 good things you
did they're gonna remember one bad thing
you did yeah you know it's just named
nature of the human being because if you
look at some of the legends in
UFC today generation they don't know if
you mentioned like let's say Matt Hughes
yeah they don't even know if you
mentioned some of the other guys Pat
Miletich well yeah there's a lot of guys
who Jeremy Horn you were like who's that
yeah and he's a legend other guys not
even close to this guy have 135 saying
in his prime he was very famous but look
little time passed by people forgot that
said there's all your doing so you're
thinking about these things now and
you're not I mean you're not somebody I
mean people think okay fighter he's not
you know you're you're somebody who's
also you were close to or becoming an
attorney degree so attorneys are really
good at looking at things from an
analytical really dissecting everything
so before you started to now you got a
really forsake and go against the grain
as we said with your parents your
culture so you really are looking at the
evidence of Islam to make sure that it's
indeed from the Creator it's not a
man-made way of like fake religion if
you look at the every religion every
religion at any point testified the God
is only one you know and then you see
here and there the people start throwing
up over there to somebody with the gut
you know he ever like a son or he have a
you know I'm saying you know and then
you start to understand like I read the
Bible Old Testament and they tell me the
New Testament well New Testament is
still Old Testament because this came
then Quran is the very very New
Testament Quran come after the Bible
right so the Old Testament was all
completely testified was God is one you
know I mean Jesus himself says God is
Alpha and Omega then in New Testament
this Trinity is came you know I mean and
as I read if you hear about the pastor
his name was ariani you never hear about
him know here is yeah yeah Aries he was
talking about though he'd yeah right the
God is one and stuff it and I read the
story when they say the Greeks and the
Romans cannot bring the total heat
because they was always on what the Xu's
you know yes so they cannot do that so
they say let's bring the Son and the
Holy Spirit yes people have to have they
already had that concept of worshipping
you know multiple
gods three four or five make him one now
yep so you know they was trying to
follow their because they know if people
is not gonna be accepting only one God
like it's in generation you know yes
people never want to believe in manga
but this is very simple to God is one
there's Ten Commandments in the Bible
okay every Christian supposed to build
the first commandment says what the God
is only one huh
so the simply breaking all the you know
what I mean so when I read it and I read
the Quran
you know the Quran makes sense for him
because Quran not just the book of the
history they have a science when they
explaining how the kid how the human
step by step became a human being
development of the human embryo early
stages is there in the Quran ya know
then they talk about the the universe
the Sun you know the everything they
have so much science even the mosquito
and I have a mosquito you know I mean
there's like this crazy so everything
over there and the God just guide you
through his prophets everything men when
you marry what you have to do if you
divorce what you have to do if you get
the woman with the child what you have
to do with orphan you know I mean every
step how you have to deal with the
business how you have to deal with the
you know this is ridiculous how you
don't show me the any other religion who
step-by-step showing you that stuff so
this is what really car this is what
really had you pursue Islam or looking
into it all the evidence and all these
things the whole complete blueprint for
living your life evidence right there
you want to see you go to the Mecca you
see the first place where the people was
worship in the cowboy you know you see
the grave over the prophet muhammad said
it set up you know so you see all this
up
the proof is over there you see with
your own eyes ya know what I mean slowly
but this main thing I like what you're
saying is just a pure monotheism what we
call to toe he'd like many people they
do get confused and they get turned away
and they you got to like put your brain
on hold when you talk about Trinity so
really was just making a shift from
believing that this whole this
philosophy that came up bottled from the
from the pagan Romans and Greeks so then
they make God into three but not three
but one and people get confused but to
the original organic way the pure way
which is that what really caps away so
many people there's only one God it's
not three just leave it alone
at 1:1 that's it I saw the a little
short video clip from the movie and the
guy bought the statue uh-huh
and he woke when he come back and he
said man why this God doesn't talk
anymore what happened I need to change
the battery yeah and the guy was sitting
over there he say he have no battery
that's done this died he said what you
mean your God is dying he say and he say
like no no he say I created he say do
you create the God he's their God create
the humans you know he hold this statue
in his hand so he said no the God hear
us all you can straight talk to him he
say then why you create a statue if we
can talk to the God you know I'm saying
he just like oh simply if you can't talk
to the guy but you see how humans are
remember the story with a moose are a
sinner when they create the bull when he
was after they see how he in front can
you imagine this sing with your own eyes
somebody opened the ocean in front of
you and save you from the slavery and
you're still gonna go and build the toad
you know what I mean you build the bull
to worship that's how humans these days
they have to see something to worship it
this were in Christian when I was
Orthodox Christian there was a draw the
call okona
yes he conned this is the picture with
some holy person you know when they
worship it
or they ask through them to the God when
the bible themselves teaching them when
the jesus himself go to the grow to the
place worship him how he did it he
kneeled down and he say Oh Father in
heaven right he did in the end he don't
say in the name of Jesus Christ because
they say this how they was teaching the
prayer of the prayer was I mean when we
read the selected Fatiha what we say in
there and say I mean you know we sorted
fat here is two steps the first when you
greeting their Allah say Allah is
merciful and everything and stuff and
then you ask him to guide you to the
straight path you know when you say I
mean so for me this I don't know man
it's uh it's real it's uh it's common
sense but it's a shame that common sense
as they say is not common practice with
many people so I think the first thing
is that because this really resonated
with you and so many people who are
coming because Islam continues to be the
fastest growing way of life in the world
because it makes sense
based on proof and evidence that's a
thin tick has an authentic book a
miraculous book the Quran if anybody
comes at it with sincere heart and mind
puts it to the test they'll see that
this is from the crater it makes sense
to only worship one and only one God but
I think the biggest Idol
nowadays that people have to break first
and foremost is themselves in their ego
I know since we're talking since we're
talking about fighting and you know
here's I was looking at I think you
think this is one of the things that
people now are worshipping this is like
so you have so many rituals you know
when you when you worship the Creator
this is act my son's belt yes so the
example I'm setting is that you know
when you start and worship obviously we
know worship the Creator is just serving
your Creator doing everything he loves
staying away from everything that he
dislikes and this is how you live a more
fruitful balanced blessed life we have
certain rituals right yeah certain
certain actions that we do throughout
the day but if you look at other
people's lives there are certain rituals
you do a fighter will do have certain
rituals he'll wake up at a certain time
yeah some maybe wake up real early could
be fudger they could be praying yeah all
right then they'll eat so many times a
day yeah we pray five times a day right
they'll fast to catch weight yeah
they're fasting from certain foods it's
a rigorous man you really like almost
torturing yourself right so then you're
doing that to achieve the belt good but
it comes with the perks to get the
status what do you think I don't know
you do see the video of Mike Tyson yeah
when he broke all the bells yet this
stuff
this is history here you are you're
history this is garbage I can say I bled
for garbage this is nothing this is just
nothing he said this is not there's
nothing yeah he said what is important
is my family in the God he said you have
to leave you know what I mean for the
gut cuz like a toy I said if they making
these key things for the kids so they
they put these things for the adults now
and we're like kids and we're chasing
chasing the bill man the point I want to
make
about the word jihad yeah okay a lot of
people here that they scared that said
you know all the him jihad is the word
even Mike Tyson says on his one
interview about the jihad jihad is when
you fight your own desires yeah like if
you were Mary this other woman you want
to go sleep with her you don't do it
this is jihad if you want to go a bunch
of stuff the RIBA you know everything in
this life what we have desire into drugs
alcohol you know all that stuff this
will be called you had with your own
soul
so you fight your own soul through your
life and there's what exactly the God
tell you to do you you know what I mean
and when you fight your own soul to stop
doing that stuff this is the real jihad
you do jihad is to establish peace and
justice in the world peace with yourself
with your Creator first and foremost so
there's a lot of these misconceptions do
you run across a lot of those did you
yourself before you totally accept it
it's not how long did it take you as an
attorney now putting it to this to the
test right sound intellect sound mind
sound reasoning how long did it take you
of an investigation that before you
concluded this is it this cannot have
come from Muhammad peace be upon him
from a group of men from the devil some
will say but this after you exclude
those actually after you because the
Quran can only come from one of these
it's either problem Mohammed he wrote
the Quran himself either it came from a
group of men conspiring together or its
from the devil once you go ahead and
knock all these out there's only one
thing left one door that's there is and
it's from the Creator you knocked all
these out how long did it take you to
knock it out that you finally realize
that this is from your Creator from the
course because you know when we live in
Russia but can they this is a war with
the church now Russians you probably
hear about that and all you see about
the Muslims are terrorists are bad
people they're killing they dead they're
dead and this is the media I never in my
life because the majority is in my
countries of Christians so I never go
across the Muslim person if I didn't
know about that nothing so you know then
later on we
have internet you know an Internet we
starts watching the stuff I start
watching I start learning start reading
the Quran and I say man this is now what
this religion preach this opposite of it
and also this lie you can see their lie
the Quran says if you kill one innocent
person it's like you kill all humanity
and your prey is gonna be in the bottom
of the Hellfire you know me so when you
could start studying the religion you
read this serie the life of the Prophet
and Sahaba you see how merciful a couple
days ago I read the one very beautiful
story about abu bakr radiallahu anhu he
when he saw was get injured in a fight
he died after the killer of his son
after he accepted Islam he came to him
and he said I was the one who killed
your son I'm came to ask for apologies
and he say and hamdullah lie you the one
who sent my son to the paradise because
he was fighting to spread the word of
the God and alhamdulillah he didn't kill
you he's not Muslim to send you to hell
fire you accept the Islam and it became
Muslim can you imagine this the father
answer and the guy who killed his son
that's deep
you know I mean so there's like this
beautiful this was a beautiful people
with the beautiful message all people
have to do is read you want to learn
about the real Muslims read I guarantee
you every other guy in your neighborhood
is Muslim you just don't even know that
the same people like you we work with
take care of a family we actually the
ones who follow the message of Jesus
Christ
yeah do you think now it's because we're
not like officially now like the first
seven eight hundred years many people
don't know that the Muslims were on top
as the super power you had and alo Spain
seventeen hundred years where Jews
Christians Muslims living together in
peace technology science everything was
that like it pinnacle of knowledge
people were coming and sending
dignitaries were sending their sons to
go ahead and learn like people right now
send their children to America and
university people were sending back home
to the men back to the Muslim to the
university to Islam did the universities
were the Muslims were people don't know
this history so we were the winning team
you can say if you want to look at it
like that today
people look at
Muslims in such a negative light because
of media because of the hate
provocateurs so that's why I Dow was
sharing this message is so crucial and
important but do you think that's what
it is because you people have that
mentality they had that mentality like
you know um they're not we're not on the
winning team because now they look at
Muslims as just in a negative light that
this keeps a lot of people away from you
know like I'll give you one example like
look at this heavyweight champion who
after after his fight he was like
bismillah Anthony Anthony Johnson first
of all I want to thank God I want to say
bismillah you know it seems like he's
there
you know his he's there but it's like
now you got the courage to get in there
and fight but now a greater courage to
come out and stand on the truth okay
well they scared you see because of all
this media and what the people think
about you they even scared to come they
read the book they see this truth but
they're scared to open up because they
don't want the people and their fan base
start say oh no no he's winning team
because they're not a no this way I
encourage people like me I was a
Christian you know I grew up in
Christian family all my family converted
my mom everybody mosiac accepted Islam
also you know all of them and you know I
mean all you have to do is learn just
open the books read talk to the people
who the scholars talk to the people who
don't know nothing about that
yeah I think people who are in the fight
game fight industry they can because you
will often you know what it is to be
humbled right yeah so you got to be
humble and you got to present yourself
in front of your Creator with sincerity
humbleness and what you are doing is you
are getting humbled by the thought of
death the departure date many people
don't reflect that we're just a number
of days were marked days and your fight
can be your last fight what if you get
you had like go back to Matt Hughes you
know what happened to him he was a
legend in the game and then he's
fortunate he got hit by a train yeah and
he was like paraplegic he was just
immobilized you know and that could
happen then he's just forgotten
people don't talk about him anymore but
this hour is menu you know you own a
horse one day and then the next day
something happened people forget about
you real quick yeah life is just move on
the only important thing in this life
okay logical let's see if you're a
businessman okay what you will be invest
in something what is eternal or
something just for time you know I mean
obviously you're gonna invest something
internal so you know there's gonna be
afterlife and it's gonna be internal so
you'll be investing in your eternal life
then you will invest in this life when
you will die and everything you have
your houses your cars your money
everything is gone there's not gonna go
with you to the grave there's gonna be
just you not your kids not your wife not
your pain no but just you that's it yeah
you in a grave you done your life is
over here so you're gonna get with you
over there what do you do through your
life did you take care of the poor
people do you did what the God tell you
about this left to do he give you a
freedom of the church are you free but
you still have to pay the price this is
the hell what is the paradise a lot of
people you know what they come to me
they say okay man if God is so good why
did so much worse in the world why did
so much bad stuff going on do I say it
is simple okay when the Allah send Adam
and Eve in the earth and the Iblees you
know a bliss give make the dua to Allah
ask him to give him time to the Judgment
Day he can prove the humans not gonna
follow him only the ones who is in Dean
you know what I mean but what he say the
freedom of the choice Allah says I'm not
gonna do nothing
letting you go I give you a time I'll
give you a prophet to guide you you do
whatever you want but in the end you
have to pay so the simple that's why the
God doesn't do nothing everything we do
we do to ourselves you know the war and
everything this is come from the people
God give you a freedom of the choice go
ahead and then you have to pay you you
can't say oh I didn't know yes you do
you know what I mean in every nation
this was a prophet who teach you who
guide you just follow the straight path
I like the example you gave being in a
supermarket and people just imagine that
you're in a supermarket and you're just
packing up everything or
convenience or a nice mall and you're
just filling up all your stuff but at
the end you got a peso you for
everything you've done in this life
there's accountability you will be asked
and you will be accountable and that's
where their judgement fits and that
makes sense that makes sense that
there'll be a day of judgment and we're
responsible and this is for not only the
the not yet Muslims who are out there
because when we say Muslims just simply
one who has submitted his or her will to
the Creator the Muslims out there who
are listening now and now they're also
getting caught up into chasing you know
just is this belt did the UFC belt is a
gold platinum you know it seems like
this one medal seemed like this
different word so it's not gold
no it's like not all you think all this
is gold so it's worth like you know that
goal you can't even sell it to me if you
want yeah I think there's not even I
think there's a plastic so how do we
when we talk to our brothers and pretty
soon probably are some our sisters are
going down that route you know leaving
the home to go training the and in the
gym with the men you know to get in the
ring because it's it's actually a
fulfillment of a prophecy a problem
Hamid peace and buzzer to be eponymous
where he said that you know you guys
will follow the ways those before you
inch by inch right if there's so much so
if they went into a lizard hole you
follow him
yeah so now not to get stuck to stay a
walking right you got woken you started
to think about the purpose of life you
looked into the Koran this book that
provides all the evidence in a message
were believable the life of problem
Hamid you accepted Islam submission to
the crater not the creation you're
living it but now dunya dunya is like
hypnotizing a lot of people was job of
Shaitan and he's over there 24 hours to
do so he promised Allah this was his
promised I'm coming from the back from
the phone from I'm gonna be you know and
what he do the biggest is money yeah
everyone is chasing the money look at
this huge this days they thrown money
here Mayweather always taking the videos
with his pack of money pack of money
like come on man you know what is gonna
get you the people are not gonna love
you with
love when you have nothing and you see
people around you you know they for real
when you have something and you see a
lot of people you don't know why they
around you yeah you know what I mean but
for me like I say I go through every
book I was a Baptist Church I was a
Jaeho witnesses Church I was in the
Mormon Church I learned a lot about the
Jewish Buddhism every other accent you
really did your homework I did and I go
to the church I was a Mormon at one
point of my life you know I mean I've
been you know witnesses and one of my
life I was Orthodox Christian one point
and not like just basic one I go to
everything they have when this was a
Christmas I was there all night like in
rush you know they stay all night at the
church and they praying and they sing in
the songs then they leave there's some
food over there because they say the
Holy Spirit is going down to bless the
food they bring in your feed your family
so I go through all these rituals you
know I wasn't like just basic so as a
Mormon I'll go through all the rituals
too and you see I see this is just I
don't want to say nothing to offend
other people but there's nothing like
the Deen no there's nothing like this
way of like oh no it's not even close if
there one is Islam this is only way and
the real truth I go through everything
man and I'm telling you the Islam is the
way Islam is the only way of life that
is god-given not a man-made not man-made
this is a God may God send us this this
the straight path to our God yeah
there's only way there's no other ways
I like the there and there's ayahs when
we say verses in the Quran with the
Creator saying in the Dina in the LA
he'll Islam the only way of life that is
acceptable so we can make this easy
because some people are confused there's
so many religions you can have so many
counter counterfeit dollar bills but
there's only one legitimate dollar bill
or currency that's legit now you have
people trying to mimic that but in the
Quran Allah is saying that the only way
of light is from this is the crater
speaking that's is acceptable in his
sight is submission to his will
that's Islam the way he sent us to us
man this is very simple you know a lot
of people told me when I talk to him but
I pray to but I'm a good person but I do
good things I say my friend you have to
pray the way they got
from you not the way you wanted you
can't do jumping jacks prayer exactly
this doesn't do you know people do that
jump attacks for Jesus jumping jacks
push-ups but the simple okay you tell
your son do something he go do opposite
do you gonna be happy with him you know
what I mean so the same with the God God
give us he guide us and he said is the
way I wanted
so we simple do it this is gonna take
five minutes of your time but the word
that would Muhammad said Islam says 2
rakaat of the Sunnah in the morning
worth more than everything in this earth
can you imagine that you have to go deep
in these words man you have to feel it
with your heart and you have to
understand what he's saying man it
reminds me but since we mentioned Jesus
like to say that many Christians who
watch this who might even be in the
fight game John Jones maybe to Zen you
know he was saying alhamdulillah but
they many people don't know I just had
someone come up to me yesterday and say
hey I watch one your programs I didn't
know that Jesus is a prophet in Islam
people don't know these basics things
that we need to get out one is that we
believe in him you cannot be a Muslim
unless you believe in love Jesus of
course that is a God like he was a human
being he was a messenger like Abraham
Moses problem Ahamed the last fun of
messenger he never said worship me as a
God he's not a literal son of God many
people don't think well I guess this
stuff he did they say I say okay Moses
did stuff too so doesn't make him bigger
the open ocean in front of people he
throw the throw the stick and became his
name no a lot of stuff a lot of prophets
did a lot of stuff this doesn't make him
be a guts you know what I mean they say
okay he born with all the father I say
okay then Adam born with our mother and
the father he's a double doubt then
those are things that help the person to
think cuz this is logical like so people
don't know we believed he was the
Messiah you know he was born with a
miraculous birth yes he was he was
talking on the cream testify you know
how he defend his MA okay yeah one from
the cradle yeah for me defending his
mother's honor yeah the same because can
you imagine your daughter come and she
say okay I'm pregnant from Holy Spirit
who's gonna believe her you know what I
mean
so you cannot say one negative thing
they just had a
I was talking about this in Brazil yeah
that they were betraying Jesus peace be
upon them as a homosexual Christians
were outraged we also stand in
solidarity with the Christians to show
that we are also outraged because we
love Jesus as a mighty messenger don't
believe in prophet you all told the Dean
do you not in the religion go to the
Hellfire if you don't believe in Jesus
so we're not the enemy we're not the
Antichrist
we're just saying what Jesus said don't
worship Me worship he would say what the
Lord I've been having the Creator
worship the One God and this is what
fascinated you and I so had you accept
Islam and saw a lot more people can go
ahead and hear what you have to say your
story and think think beyond beyond the
yeah and use that if you're already
there let's say let's talk for the
brothers out there who are who are doing
this what I like about our brother Habib
is he makes such de we talked about this
before we're not going to getting into
like you obviously you came to the
conclusion that it's not permissible
it's harmful anything else Haram is
something harmful for the human being
yeah so you came to that conclusion this
is clear in a Dean this is not something
that's accepted we should stay we should
be away from it but now someone's
already in it you also talked about
before that there are also you didn't
want to judge people in a state where
you know where they're coming from and
you were making excuses for you but what
were you saying that some people about
the food I'm not being able to put food
on their plate and you know no other
jobs and what were you saying about we
talked about before yeah again nothing
justified but just kind of having some
empathy of why people going at in that
direction this is just you know this how
to say this fitna for people they see
Habib right now how famous he is they
don't think they're not thinking they
just want to be in his spot everyone
look but they don't know what behind it
you know nobody look like one time when
Sheikh make a mention you see the big
house you see nice car you wanted I'm
okay get the problems of these people
what they have inside to maybe have a
cancer you know what I mean maybe he
don't even talk to his wife maybe his
kids is a drug addicts take this problem
with this house and you know what I mean
so the same with the father's you know
you want to be you don't know what
behind all that what he go through
behind all that you know I'm saying so
like
everybody's the fitnah you know like you
say they're chasing this masked man yeah
they think that that's it people gonna
recognize me on the street you know so
that may goes back to breaking the first
Idol is yourself your ego because what's
your intention now what are you trying
to do right you just want people to
idolize you to worship you pretty much
what the purpose you doing it burp is
this to get over there and make it our
to the people or the purpose to bit
famous get the girls and get the money
so you that's that's a form of actually
associating partners with allah many
people don't know the concept of [ __ ]
this is very dangerous it's a very thin
line that you don't want to fall into
yeah very dangerous
they say they interviewed people a
majority of people when they asked what
would make you happy
like what do you what would you want
they said to win the lotto and then they
did a study for those people that
actually did win a lot of most of them
were even more miserable yeah yeah so
that is this is like lotto for now for
many people when in the bail less money
you have
I know one thing less you're gonna
answer in front of Allah yeah no I mean
a lot of people don't understand and if
you have a money you better be on a team
to spend this money on the right way did
you see how people what he did he go to
Africa you know what I mean and he did a
lot of good work over there yeah so you
know I mean me I will not recommend to
Muslims to fight and do all that stuff
you know I will actually recommend be
away from it but I will recommend them
to work out like brother Eddie the black
belt jujitsu you know you have to be
tough not just mentally you have to be
tough physically to you know in our
Sunnah you know that shooting the error
arrow arrow whatever you call it
swimming and riding the horse this mean
you have to be physically active you
know that's what's representing that's
representing you have to be physically
active in these days people don't wanna
they think all we have to be the doctor
is a lawyer but you don't know you have
to work out to make sure you're
physically is there - yeah this is what
I like about Habib our brother Habib is
that and for the people who are there
already in it right yeah sure loud they
get out right and I heard he's getting
ready to retire he especially I they had
some boxers and some people who died
recent it's walk up some some people who
are these days actually
one of the guy was a Muslim yeah Maxime
de - if he was from Dagestan - and I
hear from the brothers you know he was
Muslim
yeah and can you imagine you died in
ring you know stuff like this this kind
of humiliating you know there's a bad
death follow me Allah you know forgive
his sins and I mean but I'm telling you
man you have to
you gotta think yeah you have beyond the
plastic you have think because all that
I know man you know we're sitting here
we think like this - but be in his spot
be making that money be famous like this
there's not it easy just to walk away
yeah let's take a bigger man and you
know that man you know I mean but you
have to think man you have to think
about God why are you here you're not
here to do that okay you already made it
get out and start spread the word yeah
start to make you know what I mean start
to work to the next life yeah you know
you have to do the good deeds to deserve
the paradise man huh you know the the
story that the man were a lost want all
of the credit happens the earth he came
I'm sorry he was there was a town and
there was one worshiper there okay yeah
and this worshiper was worshiping along
right but you imagine many people not
even worshiping along yeah but this
person he wasn't calling people towards
the pure monotheism doing the Dawa
wasn't inviting to good
calling people away from the harms of
life you know away from the evil and
what did Allah say you know he's about
to destroy this town this place where
people were just in a final these people
that just they went away they started to
turn towards paganism idolatry
you know materialism and everything but
Allah says start with this man first you
know so you also have in the Quran where
a lost one thoughts tell about those
people who were breaking the Sabbath you
know they said they try to set you know
play with the Dean and they tried to set
up the nets you know just condensing a
story but at the end there was the
people the ones Allah save are the ones
who are inviting people so now you have
this platform you're someone let's say
like Habib I may I mention his name
because many people don't know many of
these
other fighters yeah but this is a good
thing now lease you're out there trying
to invite people to goodness you're
trying to invite people to use that
platform to be a good example not to be
mellow guide the Conor is exactly the
spot for him where he's supposed to
explain who Muslims are Marshall I mean
you have to tell when other terrorists
they show us on the TV you can speak up
now we're not oppress the people we're
not here to push you and convert you to
our religion we are here to show you the
way of life we're not gonna knock on
your door like some people do but we're
gonna talk for ourselves you know I mean
we know the terrorists
we're not the killers we're not
spreading the we do we're telling you
what the Bible actually teaches you to
don't drink alcohol don't sleep with
many woman's you know I mean don't do
the drugs don't kill don't Rob you can
marry more it's a toss Stroh's above
what 1700 yeah but ten commandments
treat them like a woman's supposed to be
treated oh these guys like there's equal
like these these guys are out there you
know raping women all that and stuff
brother they tale I believe fight train
with the people they tell him you know
how is the two wives I say my man you
have a wife and you have a three side
chicks yes so what are you talking about
you know I mean but like I say thank
amendments this is what we do if I'm
coming to you and I'm telling you don't
drink don't beat your wife don't Rob
don't do that stuff and you telling me
I'm a terrorist because of that but this
how it is in these days if you're trying
to spread the good word you know what I
mean if you tryna you know like back in
Russia man when you have a beard and
you're just the proper way they give you
trouble yeah I don't stand just for that
man you know what I mean like we talked
about that before but looking at the
pictures of Jesus he said you have a
beer they all have a beer with your
promise the big it fights the raise of
camcorders yeah mother man she was
winning the a job uh-huh you know she's
car become yeah the day I was flying
when I flying to Chicago where I see
them this sister the Christian sister
she was wearing the hijab she was
completely covered yeah I mean but yeah
now I usually mentioned now it's anti
anti aging anti cancer the UV rays the
pollen all this stuff they can
benefits you got people who aren't even
religious they're growing the beards
because of all the benefits I was saying
like a line without the mane is a
lioness and without the beard is a woman
back back to I was saying so you have a
okay if you have that stage now that
stage that tomorrow you can be quickly
forgotten utilize that stage we've often
repeated it to go ahead like and I
mentioned not Mohammed Ali a lot because
he used to actually sign these brochures
and what what Jesus in Islam what is
Islam because people they want his
autograph he would sign these things
educational pamphlets and he would give
to people so at least now they're not
gonna throw away his signature
but maybe inshallah they're gonna read
it open it or their family would you
don't all you have to do is throw the
seat in their heart Ya Allah gonna you
know grow it then yeah they just need to
understand who Muslims are so they stop
hating without the reason yeah how could
you hate the person without the reason
you just see the Muslim did you hate him
you know this you can't hate a prison
without knowing him you know I mean but
do you see that this is done a lot of
some good where people have seen and
been intrigued like by Habib's you know
compared to a lot of the other the the
the conor mcgregor's and people who have
this this cavalier attitude they're just
really disrespectful and whatnot when
they see someone like a beep who's
well-mannered you know respect still
lives with his parents
it takes care it takes care of his
parents too sure you a good character
you know people look at it and then like
him yeah cuz this how's a person
supposed to be and he showing the
manners in Islam would teach him that
who Islam you know you got you got a
pointed back to the sponsor you know
people with the rebound
yeah the sponsors Islam the Quran yeah
this is where he gets that exactly this
why he get the good character this is
very easy stuff he did for Dustin
Poirier - yeah there's a lot of money
man there's a lot of money to just give
to give away they like this for charity
you know that's amazing I want yeah it
since you mentioned that because Dustin
Poirier at first he was talking about
this is one of your training partner
right yeah you trained wait wait you
trained with what stung me at Miami guy
Oh mess with all he's in your camp there
your Romero
call me calving call me Collington kobe
coming to has some good things to say
when you are we're gonna made a video
here and he said on they will help me
feel about the muslims in i'm so listen
how you feel about muslims tell me i
have nothing but love and respect for
everything muslim in the world and and
anybody that wants to your viewpoints or
your viewpoints and i would never judge
anybody for what they believe in and I
have nothing but love for everybody
respect so you don't have nothing
against the Muslim oh yeah much love and
respect to the Muslims I I respect all
you guys and what you guys believe it
[Music]
yeah okay so all these people now that
look at Habib and now you look at his
demeanor the way he represents himself
you'll go ahead and you'll point back to
your sponsors but people think men okay
this is just this individual he's a
humble guy what now no but it's actually
your sponsor meaning what is teaching
you this is Islam because he probably be
doing the same thing like everybody else
of course cuz he will have no values you
know what I mean like we have a rules
where we follow it you know what I mean
in the rules set up by the Quran through
the life you have to have a good manners
you have to treat your neighbors nice
you have to you know take care of your
parents yeah and stuff like this so this
will he learn it and this what do you
have to do right now to point it to the
people so they understand yeah this is
beautiful worship one God this is what
attracted you to Islam the evidence of
the crown and be morally upright of
course yeah not a perfect human being
you're gonna make mistakes but then
people say hold on they say Ali then who
died for your sins now like okay now
yeah you're not the perfect human being
you're gonna you're sinful you make
mistakes but who's gonna absolve you of
your sins exactly I'm not can just give
the backpack to my kids so they can't
carry everybody if I kill the person I'm
going to jail not my kids going to the
jail yeah
this doesn't make any sense right yeah I
don't know so they say look Jesus he
died for your sins what do you say about
that logically doesn't make any sense so
I can do go do whatever I want spread
the corruption in the earth because he's
already dead for my sins so how does it
work in Islam yeah everybody's
gonna answer for his own sins everyone
you're dead your mom you we're not gonna
answer for yourself exactly this makes
sense okay if this doesn't then why we
don't change the law if I commit the sin
I say okay he can do it go do the time
for me how does forgiveness work in
Islam you can forgive the person but if
you do a sin against yourself for God
and you ask the God for forgiveness make
sense so it straight up you don't have
no idols you don't have nobody else you
don't have a partner I don't need to ask
you to ask for me I ask God straight up
huh nice to do raise my hand and ask God
for forgiveness yeah do you feel because
last time I saw you there was a really
good news we had we had one of the
fighters there who took his Shahada yeah
but do you see now that again someone
will be very courageous we'll get in
there and this is what we deem men like
we think okay a man who's getting in
there and you know does this kind of
martial art but now courage is also part
of being an alpha male you want to call
it today you know someone who's just
who's morally upright and who also has
courage now someone accepts let's say
everything else they'll try everything
else but now they're listening to us
they listen to your story that makes
sense okay I'm gonna die let me think
about my purpose everything around me
has a Parisian that belt has a purpose
what's my purpose they go ahead and they
open their mind they're hard look in
Islam but now it's like hold on where
how do they get this courage to go ahead
like Anthony Johnson probably wants to
do but media and not on the one-tenth
scale now someone accepts Islam do you
see that that they're like really
nervous about it talking about it or or
even many fade out because of lack of
courage the problem is because they
scared what people gonna think it's
scared of what people gonna think yeah
as long as you don't care what people is
gonna think about you and what God is
gonna think about you because when you
die the God is gonna be the one who's
gonna you're gonna be answer in front
yeah you know but you think about the
people you know it's me as a cover I'd
like with my family this was a very hard
time explain to him okay we
this type of meat we need this you know
when you pray in front of them
everything is different for them because
they never sold it and they don't know
so for them they scare what my family is
gonna think what does you know if you
see this the truth you have to accept it
yeah you have to go with it this would
show you a real man
yeah the saying goes that if you don't
stand for this truth and what you
believe in you'll fall for anything
exactly and we see that happening so but
I think if you if you take baby because
it can be I mean we there are these
challenges it can be very trying at
times to go against the social pressures
and that but we've seen also that if
you're committed little by little taking
those baby steps that allow the crater
if you show commitment he will
strengthen you but if you want to go
ahead and do everything else and you
don't care about sinning and about you
know what God Almighty Allah has to say
so you're not scared there but over here
you skate you fear more the people
instead of fearing your Creator that's a
problem can be a world champion the most
strong human being in the earth and
you've been scared of the opinion of the
people on you you know wow let's see you
see that a lot in this industry see that
you see this person so strong and you
know when you ask him
are you wanna be high yes I believe and
his voice is shaking and stuff like this
like like come on man
you're the strongest man in the area
what's wrong with you you're the
strongest man like Anthony Josie's the
best boxer in the world right now you
know the strongest man in the world you
can't say you know and you've been
scared work to come out and say my
Muslim you have to be proud of it God
choose you from the billions of billions
of people being a truth man yeah to die
being a paradise man you have to be you
know but they don't got it like prophets
that I said I what do you say the
religion is stuck over here it is
getting to your heart you're not gonna
be scared of nobody
yeah you mentioned something about
people saying I'm a good person you know
I talked to God or yeah but you you see
this also I see this a lot where people
they'll say you know I talk to God but
that's one thing but how many people
listen to God that's another thing okay
it's just like me and you having a
conversation where you're talking but or
are you talking to your child or so not
but they're not listening to you
you know they're not there talking to
you but when you tell them what to do
they're not listening so how many people
are actually talking to the car you just
talking talking but thank God Almighty
sent us a lot of sense does what he
wants us to do you're not listening the
problem is not just with non-muslims
whoever this problem with the Muslims do
big time will tell Muslims now they
don't even listen to God The Guardian
especially people who speak Arabic and
understand the Quran and it still don't
listen they know their God talking to
them and tell them what to do and they
don't listen let's start basic things
like establishing salah and you're like
exactly why you know pray yeah how does
it all work over here man come on man I
prayed the airport I pray in the
airplane I pray everywhere I am we
prayed the gin with you last time it was
nice nice to see which we stopped that
was a beautiful thing about all the the
brothers the Dagestani they stopped
raining they must repent for the fire
and guess what the people around who was
not moving they respected yeah you know
I mean if you put yourself around the
people like that they're gonna respect
it ya know I mean so you have to put
your foot down man people they often say
well I got a clean heart yeah it's kind
of like saying I got a clean mouth but I
don't brush my teeth do nothing with it
because you have to follow the rules you
follow the you know okay this is a red
light you know if you pass it you know
you're gonna get ticket you believe in
it 100% yeah you don't believe the God
tell you're gonna punish you for some
type of things you're not gonna do you
tell you're gonna punish your first
sellout why you don't come me and you
why you don't do it so that you know are
you believer or you not yeah let's talk
about this before we close people like
talking about these conversations and
maybe we can throw some more Deen in
there so yeah why you see Conor McGregor
he's chasing now he's going out of his
way to try to fight habib again what do
you think about that you think he's
gonna what he's really and why did they
give him they give him because all these
other guys like habib he says look man
you got a like wait you shot your turn
all right but he's trying to jump ahead
of everybody to come in and quantum
mcgregor is a walking money back hold
his guys a cure when he get beat up by
the habib you saw that after that i say
man is just a business just a business
you know he's not real it's not a
personality he represents he do this
just to make money to entertain people
like WWE this is a fake personality so
he created two Internet the people to
make money for Habib is the Atlit is the
goal he already beat him he don't need
to prove not that he don't need it but
if you want to have money you know what
I mean and make more money this is the
money fight the same with Mayweather
when he fight Mayweather do you really
think he will ever be the mayweather the
the Conor McGregor know everybody knows
that but people want to see this because
his entertainment you know I mean but
why this was four corner he know you're
not gonna be made with the best boxer of
the old tap this is the money money
fight you know what I mean people make
money was Habib's serious about wanting
to fight Floyd also you think so if you
want to make good money those are the
big money fight that's big money fight
yeah there's the money fights for her
fans you know but athletes who is a
professional they know you know yeah
this is different you can't be a boxer
guy and just jump into the wrestling and
became Olympic champion and wrestling
you know different sport how do you
think this it's he got a today sign
everything for the Tony Ferguson yeah
they're gonna fight that thing in April
on some yeah yeah yeah didn't he try to
fight so many times before and it just
always something will come something
going on between them two men I don't
know but this is gonna be the best fight
for sure man yeah this would be now this
one
there's our desire top said they have
nothing to prove I hope you're gonna
retire yeah that's what I'm saying you
know this would be amazing if he came
out at the end and he said look I'm
doing this for my creator for a law you
know give it up for the Dean
shall I you know this is what I was
always hoping he gonna do yeah cuz a lot
of people look at him a lot of youths
he's the example for them but he gave
her a good he gave he gave some good
advice he don't he don't advise people
did he say that or no advice not study
and stuff like he give a good advice he
gave advice for a woman to don't do that
yeah take care of the family like that
yeah give like I say he a very good
character yeah you know I mean but
ensure like I say a lot of people
judging all of the people throw the big
words
but like I say you never gonna make
people happy yeah you know so all you
want is relation between you and Allah
and this most important because we don't
know what he do with his money how we
know maybe he feed all the Africa right
now we don't know we don't know what he
do is between him and Allah you know in
the end of the day the prophecy rates
around says what you have to defend the
owner of your brother yeah you know and
find a million excuses and never judge
you know what I mean here is the price
that is set up our days the people he
sealed know he's committed Haram he's
Haram ey you have to say that you know
is between him and Allah make dua for
your brother yes so we have to do you
know yeah cuz these days Muslims hate on
each other more than numbers and hate on
you know I mean you know how it is you
go to the comments you reading people
attacking each other for small things
man
I like subhanAllah man Allah call your
brother and sister in the Quran and you
acting like you know yeah you know the
point I wanted to mention before I was
with Dustin Poirier yeah we're at first
at first he was saying that I'm going to
enemy territory something like that but
then this was really nice to see that he
went over there and he experienced Islam
in a sense of the hospitality the warmth
as people get brainwashed to think okay
I'm going because he obviously said that
because of the media your highest range
too because he trained with the Muslims
you all there Muslims they know was they
respect us they see with Muslims they
know we go to the prayer and Juma were
trained in front of them they know they
respect us you know we trained together
who help each other out and then when he
go over there he see the hospitality of
the people yeah he see the people was
training him like a king so he know he
apologized when he was doing he said man
I've been treated better than that
treated back homies wait doesn't Poirier
he said what he said I was treating
better here that I would be treated
better by the Muslims then then he
tracked over here mention like a king
they gave I talked to the coach one of
the coach in his corner died Ali his
father was a Muslim too yeah
so he told me man we love it over here
they treat us very very good over here
yeah it's kind of opposite to what
you're hearing thinking they're gonna
cut our heads off they get all the
you push they think you're gonna be in
the middle of desert riding the camels
and actually they came and see the best
car is the best technology over there
yeah you know there was amazed yeah but
if people would dig a little bit more
this is beautiful because having the
best o'clock the best like what the
experience the hospitality really
shifted hopefully he's thinking and then
he can go above and beyond and really
think because people they just kind of
just do what they seen their parents or
their environment so they put the cross
on you know they go ahead and suck it
becomes like a superstition and they put
God like in a bottle it's like genie in
a bottle you know they do this for like
more of a good luck thing but people do
what you did really investigate because
you come from a Christian background you
go above and beyond blindly accepting
many of these practices and look deeper
and ask the Creator alone for guidance
he's gonna facilitate away because you
know that doesn't make sense many of
these things these practices these days
I always have a question everything I
did and I always ask God to guide me
because I really want to be in a
straight path yeah you always ask the
waiters alone always ask God alone alone
I always ask him to guide me to the
straight path I say I feel this is
something wrong with it please guide me
yeah please guide me guide me guide me
and Allah guide me to do Salaam yeah so
I often just remind people this is out
of the love you know that we're sharing
these things because there's many people
who are stuck in a rut they're on xanax
they're on drugs they're on
antidepressants and that's not getting
full with chasing materialism fame money
but when you find out really what the
purpose of life is you start living it
and that's Dean that's submission to the
creator of creation that's Islam that's
where you get that contentment peace
happiness that money cannot buy
physically you can be happy with the
woman we're having money buy whatever
you want but did but you know physically
you get tired every time you buy one
phone the next phone coming you want it
right you get tired of the things but
mentally mentally meaning like
spiritually this is the best you never
get tired when you close to Allah you
always happy you have a stress you have
anything in your life you sell hamdullah
you're always happy because Allah put
your in this stage because you close to
him you know I mean
and the thing you mentioned with Dustin
Poirier like you see he goes over there
he changed his mind so that's exactly
what you're doing a den show you spread
the word to change people mind so they
can deeply look at Islam and Muslims and
understand we're not the enemy yes
that's the main thing I like what you
said we're not the enemy even though we
love we feel this is the greatest gift
that we can share with you is this way
of life Islam but at the end of the day
we still respect your decision if you
want to stay upon the way that your upon
that's fine but we have to understand
that Muslims are here to stay
Christians are here to stay and whatever
else that you do you're gonna have to be
accountable on the day of judgment but
at the end of the day we need to work
together to make this world a better
place so we can live in peace and
harmony and we can agree to disagree on
some things but we should cooperate on
the good things that we have in common
and avoid many of these these false
things that separate us people argue
always you have your way we have ours
he's the ultimate judge nothing to argue
about but if people look at it from a
place of love that we share these things
it's not like why if you tried to invite
someone to your house you're not trying
to invite him to your house because he's
your enemy exactly so if you're trying
to invite him to to the purpose of life
to this boy of life is because you care
for him because you want him in a
paradise like you man you want a good
friend but this they don't think they
think okay you want to do something bad
to me my man I'm trying to invite you to
the paradise yeah the house of peace
yeah cuz back in the days nobody
inviting me yeah I found the truth and I
Chyna share this truth with you you
accept it or not this is on you what
advice before we conclude would you give
for an inspiring athlete now who wants
to pursue this cage fighting and to be
in there you being a professional
fighter so many fights you've done all
this now you've realized that this is
not the way to go as long what what
would you tell him I'll tell his waste
of time and there's not worth it you
train you train for yourself to be
physically strong health purposes you
know what I mean stuff like this you go
to school but you focus on your
next life this most important thing I
don't tell you to go to the University
don't get a good degree don't make money
is do it I don't forgot why you're here
and what your purpose Allah says I
create the humans and the jinns for what
for worshipping me you know there's our
purpose of the life to worship Allah
spread the world be good to the you know
live this life the way that God want
from you this is your purpose of the
life not to get this plastic belt and
other stuff so don't be chasing
something we're not going to help you in
a beautiful vice thank you ally Cato
cough here we finally had you here in
the studio on the Dean show and shelah
we'll see you again sometime soon we'll
send you back over there to the warm
weather and then you come back here when
it's warmer thank you for being with us
may Allah bless you and reward you for
sharing having that courage to not only
live this Deen but to share it with
others said I want economy well your
aleikum Salaam I've got and thank you
guys for tuning in so the message is
simple that you got one life to live and
that life shouldn't be spent chasing
your desires chasing the place plastic
belt but the Creator out of his mercy
and love he sent messengers throughout
time and that message is always the same
worship the one God the Creator not the
creation don't worship yourself your ego
break through that Idol and go ahead and
start to sincerely earnestly seek to
know the truth why you've been created
those gloves on your hand have a purpose
to watch on your hands as a purpose the
steering wheel has a purpose the nose on
your face has a purpose and the list
goes on what about you the human being
you don't have a purpose doesn't make
sense
seek out really what your purpose is
before the death date the departure day
comes and you'll find if you're sincere
all those answers to all those questions
in this beautiful way of life that Jesus
lived Moses Abraham the last the final
messenger sent to mankind Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
in Islam look into it thank you for
tuning in subscribe if you haven't
already and we'll see you next time here
on the Deen show God willing inshallah
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum